you hear it everywhere DLS has this DLS
has that but what is it and why is it
doing the impossible this AI based
technology is being talked about in the
media a great deal and it is supposedly
a way of dramatically speeding up
computer games and Virtual Worlds so
does this really work well when Johnson
Huang nvidia's CEO says that every
single Pixel on your screen for these
games will not be rendered but will be
generated soon presumably by an AI that
really got my attention that sounds
insane and if hearing this you think
that this cannot possibly be true I
don't blame you for a second we can't
just create all this footage there has
to be a proper system that can compute
Reflections diffuse interactions and all
that all right well not quite in 2018 I
had a little project where I wanted to
generate photorealistic images of
material models quickly now generating
an image through Ray tracing talk up to
40 to 60 seconds and that was a bit too
long for my taste so I tried to write a
neural renderer that could take just the
description of a material model and it
would immediately in real time
synthesize what it would look like and
it was able to do all this not in 60
seconds but in three milliseconds yes it
was 20 000 times faster however it was
limited to this very scene so how did
this research field improve in the last
five years do we have anything more
usable now oh boy if only I could tell
you well meet dlss deep learning super
sampling this is a system where hardware
and software works together to create an
incredible experience where games and
Virtual Worlds really run faster than
what should be possible so how well as
of the LSS version 3 get this by
generating 7 out of every 8 pixel that
appears on the screen yes more than 85
percent of the pixels are just generated
not computed by for instance Ray tracing
or traditional techniques yes that
sounds flat out impossible but it is
possible the first step is running super
resolution in real time this means that
the course image goes in and an AI finds
out if we pretended that this is a fine
image instead what are the details that
are missing and it synthesizes those
details second Optical flow we can look
at two adjacent frames of the video game
and try to estimate what has happened
between them and where things are going
with this entire intermediate frames can
be synthesized as creating the illusion
as if the game was running smoother than
our Hardware can run it combining the
two together with a pool of very few
pixels that are computed both image
quality and smoothness can be improved
at the same time what a time to be alive
but it does not stop there it gets
better they have also announced dlss 3.5
so hopefully all this can be improved
even further through something that they
call Ray reconstruction oh my goodness
this is going to be so good but how well
normally when we perform Ray tracing we
simulate the path of millions and
millions of rays and bounce them around
in the scene and if we can't afford to
wait for up to hours at a time for an
image we will have to settle for a
really noisy image like this the noising
techniques exist that try to guess what
the missing information could be but
they are not perfect not even close some
important details between objects can be
missed entirely and still Reflections
can be a lot less clear than in a full
simulation and unfortunately we have a
problem it gets even worse this image
will undergo an upscaling step where
these errors get magnified even more
denoising and upscaling are two separate
steps typically done by two separate
models so why not do both of them with
the same AI model and now Ray
reconstruction enters the scene it
learned on a ton more information than
the previous models five times more
training data was given to it and look
at this step this one is right on the
money this is tailored to retain high
frequency information fine details to
make sure that that before the upscaling
step we have the highest quality
information available so is it better
than what denoisers did before oh my
goodness look at that we finally get
that shadowy region back that was filled
in by incorrect information with the
denoisers before yummy so good and that
high frequency information retaining
capability can also be witnessed here
loving it now note that ideally here we
talk about peer-reviewed research papers
where we can see all the weak points and
failure cases that is my home turf this
is not a research paper so it is harder
for me to find the flaws so bear in mind
that it may have weaknesses that were
not shown here and in the meantime this
technology is being handed out to
millions and millions of people all
around the world and it is incredible so
this will be available only for the
shiniest newest graphics card owners
right well hold on to your papers fellow
Scholars because here comes the best
part no this comes to all RTX graphics
cards even the older ones that you can
pick up for a couple hundred bucks this
can breathe new life into aging Hardware
which is highly appreciated note that
the particular game or app you're
running has to be ready for dlss 3.5 for
all this magic to happen now I am a
light transport researcher by trade I
dream with rays of light and Ray tracing
if you will so I am incredibly happy to
see this technology make it into the
hands of real users in the real world in
such an incredible way and make no
mistake this is not perfect by any means
there are games where it does not appear
to work very well and some people prefer
to not use it at all anywhere however
note that this is still Nissan
technology and it can already synthesize
more than 85 percent of these frames
which is something that I thought would
only be possible in a science fiction
movie maybe not even there I am
absolutely stunned by these results even
with their weaknesses and don't forget
to invoke the first law of papers the
first law of paper says that research is
a process do not look at where we are
look at where we will be two more papers
down the line weights and biases
provides tools to track your experiments
in your deep learning projects their
system is designed to save you a ton of
time and money and it is actively used
in projects at prestigious Labs such as
openai Toyota research GitHub and more
and the best part is that weights and
biases is free for all individuals
academics and open source projects it
really is as good as it gets make sure
to visit them through
wnb.me
2mp or just click the link in the video
description and you can get a free demo
today our thanks to weights and biases
for helping us make better videos for
you